both of us we work for on the same
station in Brazil it's the second
largest to view news station in Brazil
uh most some of our shows are number one
in the country
um it's it's and it's it's a
one-year-old television it's growing 80
88 year old company one-year-old
television was radio it was a radio yeah
it was a radio before that and our TV
station
got censored by court order there were
certain words we couldn't use they're
not going to believe it it's true we
were not supposed to say on air that
Lula is an ex-con is an ex-con or or
he's guilty we are not supposed to say
that by court order
he gets off in a technicality 25
five thousand yeah five thousand dollars
and they have the right to answer to
answer and to respond to it dictatorship
it is addictive it's a prior prior to
what we say and the temperature is high
like if you search on Google uh what
happened just yesterday or or two days
ago in goya's Guyana I mean if that's
the case they invaded they invaded the
assembly assembly the State Assembly
because they were trying to pass uh
increases tax increases and the the
people are angry in Brazil right now if
that's the case they're doing that what
campaign would be an interesting
campaign if the people from Brazil are
listening to this and you believe Lula
is an ex-con are fantastic hashtag would
be hashtag Lula X Khan oh no and let
that go Trend and that's because at this
point the guy that's running Twitter is
a guy named Ilana I don't know if you've
heard Elon this guy but uh Twitter right
we try to reach out to him because
Twitter and Brazil was being yeah he did
reply to my my post but we we
I don't believe he's aware of the
importance importance of Twitter in
Brazil right now because Twitter is
still censoring people more than the
courts because the courts can it's only
how can they do that though well because
according more than half the people
mainstream media pressure like no no no
no no no employees in Brazil are the
same still the same they fire half of it
but the other half how many employees
Twitter Brazil how many employees does
uh I don't know but 80 of them have a
lot of purple hair so it's like did you
hear about what Elon found yesterday in
his uh office did you see what he showed
yesterday in his office go to your last
Twitter account and show the little clip
of 15 seconds and with the audio on it
uh pretty wild what Elon found yesterday
in his office at Twitter headquarters
which is like what the hell go to Media
go to Media okay so it's the pops up
okay actually go back there you go right
there do the audio
do the audio so we can enter
things and there's an entire oh my
entire closet full of secret closet of
hashtag woke the t-shirts here we are uh
yeah at the March things and there's an
entire
entire this is employees at Twitter
wearing their shirts they stay woke
pause it the only thing they didn't do
there is work yeah do I look surprised
so in Brazil Twitter is still censoring
people so my my girlfriend's mother was
censored from Twitter I'm talking about
a 62 normal old lady from Brazil
and she's she was censored by Twitter
and and again second time and Twitter is
still censoring more Brazilians than the
Supreme Court because the Supreme Court
can only censor as so many people they
can they can't do it for thousands of
people but Twitter with their
staff and their algorithms and all that
they can they can ban more people and
and so just an example the hashtag
Brazil was stolen
it was a big hashtag started trending
after an Argentinian guy denounced uh
the the the the the problems with
Brazilian like he found inconsistencies
with the results with the results after
he denounced that in a live streaming uh
YouTube took down his live stream and
before he ended uh the the
Tweeter hashtag Brazil was telling me
was trending and Twitter took the
hashtag down and that's the big tax
censoring not not court orders big Tech
so who's not censoring is YouTube sensor
in his Facebook sensory is is anybody
not censoring no everybody's let me give
you an example I put the report of the
Argentinian guy with the inconsistence
in my telegram Channel okay I have a
telegram Channel with a little over a
hundred thousand people I put it the
original report and I said I want people
to look into that and see if that's true
or not because that's what a journalist
do you ask for other experts opinion so
I make it public I made it public
I got a court order of the Supreme
electoral Court Superior electoral Court
taking down my shutting down my telegram
account for a week
just for sharing a report
and I was like what do I have access to
the charges against me nope I never
received any citation any I was never
served I don't have access to the
process and by the way if you guys don't
know I think Rodrigo both of you guys
have over 1.1 million followers on
Twitter five million and I'm not
certified yet yeah I have 1.1 one not
certified we've got to pay you eight
bucks hurry up and pay for eight bucks
yeah but so with all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red or
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future
spread toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]